Hall der Mann weiß was sich gehört außer
seiner Mutter hätte wohl niemand von
Bushido erwartet dass er irgendwann mal
die Kurve kriegt sie sagte mach du bist
ein vernünftiger junge auch wenn du
scheiße BST du wirst irgendwann
vernünftig werden und mittlerweile
verstehst du weiß meine Mutter auf jeden
Fall dass aus mir was geworden doch
Bushido will noch mehr und zwar was
richtig seriöses wie er in der Online
talkshowoom.de erklärte ich will noch
Halligalli machen und irgendwann ist
dann noch endegelände dann mache ich
Familie mit mit mit hoffentlich Vieren
Kindern und meiner Traumfrau und wenn
ich das auch irgendwann geschafft habe
und ich nichts meh zu tun habe so dann
habe ich mir eh überlegt ob ich erstmal
Bürgermeister von Berlin werde und wenn
ich das geschafft habe dann keine Ahnung
dann muss mal gucken was ich alles
machen muss entweder Bundespräsident
oder Bundeskanzler oder so für Bushido
eine konsequente Fortsetzung seiner
Karriere ich ich find das okay weil ich
meine ich betreibe ja jetzt schon
Meinung ma meinungsmachen mit mein der
Musik viele Leute hören mich ja auch
oder hören auch auf mich ich kann Sachen
bewirken in der Musik ich kann Sachen
bewirken in der Politik und ja mal
gucken ich meine ich denke mal so ich
bin eh auch so ein Prototyp so von vom
neuen deutschen auch oder auch
vielleicht auch vom neuen Politiker
weißt du
weil Deutschland sieht halt anders aus
als vor 50 Jahren und wenn Bushido
erstmal an den Schalthebeln der Macht
setzt wird es sich wahrscheinlich noch
mehr
verändern